[Music]
have you guys
heard the juicy juicy drama about
uh dan bilzerian and how fake he is no
oh yeah i heard that um his own company
ignited schooling him for
maxing out the credit cards for his
lifestyle wait this is an interesting
way to
phrase it is this the fancy dude with
the hot people and the beard
on the boats the buff guy with the beard
and the hot chicks yup
beards and guns and butts so you know
how he's just famous for being like a 12
year old boy with a lot of money sure
because he just has like a whole bunch
of girls around him all the time
flashing cash like
a whole bunch of like lavish lifestyle
um
well turns out that he
is the son of a guy who has previously
done a lot of like did illegal [ __ ] he
went to jail because he
stole a lot of money the government's
been trying to get about like 50 million
dollars from this man
he's a he's a rich kid like he was born
into wealth
right so but the government never got
this about 50 million dollars from the
dead
and then all of a sudden here years
later
dan bilzerian comes out and is like yup
i got 50 million dollars from winning it
in poker which
by the way the the most successful
poker players like the max amount that
like the winnings
has been like about 30 mil like yeah
that's like i think those feel ivy maybe
but yeah i don't know i don't know their
names but
yeah you're right you're right 50 mil is
crazy exactly that's like
bananas i thought it was like
accumulated 50 million
well he claims that that's how he won it
right through
playing poker but then like the best
poker players are like
he sucks at playing like his skill level
is like that's what i heard too
yeah yeah so and then uh all of a sudden
he just has his 50 mil right so people
are not even his real name dan bilzerian
maybe something else bilzerian is his
name because that
basically he's like paris hilton or like
uh steve aoki or like
his his dad was a well-known real estate
developer
his last name has some sort of legacy
too yeah it's like kardashian
like that like bilzerian is like
a rich hollywood family i thought i was
like a play on billionaire or like
a billionaire no it's a billionaire it's
like an armenian name i think
yeah i don't know wait so basically he's
acting like he won the money when really
it was
well the this is speculation where he
got his money from is speculation and
people are thinking
well maybe it's that money that the dad
never gave back to the government and
that's oh
that makes sense but the reason why he's
making headlines right now
is because of his company ignite they
recently
published their their public annual
reportings
because hit ignite is a publicly traded
company
and so there's investors stockholders
involved and so they need to know where
the money's going so he does do some big
[ __ ]
because i don't own nothing that's
publicly traded or i gotta print [ __ ]
out at the end of the year
yeah no yeah he in in canada is where
he's being publicly traded
okay and different rules over there
i don't know but they did find that
ignite
lost 50 million dollars
and pretty much like like financial
people like financial youtubers
are really looking into the entire
report and they're like breaking it down
they're like
this company is about to go under like
they're about to go they're about to
declare bankruptcy
and what about all the hot chicks what
are they going to do with that well
that's not
so the thing is like also the former
president of the company
is suing yeah this uh ignite for like
wrongful determination
and for retaliation because he pushed
back on
dan bilzerian's like spending because he
was using ignite as like his personal
piggy bank
so some of the things that they flagged
like the accountants
they flagged uh the machine gun
they flecked eight hundred and forty
three thousand fourteen dollars and six
cents in company expenses that appear to
be personal in nature which included
payments charged um on one of dan
bilzerian's credit cards
a half million dollar yacht rental a
six-figure
two-night trip to london a 65 000
four elements guns and star wars sets
that one fair he's still a kid on the
inside
but a star wars set there's more a
50 000 bed frame
oh my god 50 000. i thought i went kind
of ham because i spent
a couple thousand dollars but uh
did you spend 75 000 on a paintball
field
or eighty-eight thousand dollars on a
vault wait he's not even buying the
business he's just renting it out
damn fifty thousand dollars for a bed
frame
do dreams actually come true
yeah and also the comp ignite paid to
boost
bilzerian's instagram followers uh they
picked
really 26 000 to boost his instagram
followers
to how many though wait because it might
be worth it
wait here's the thing if i actually had
that much money i don't know if i would
be doing all that
like that's exactly what everyone's
saying it's like you'd be doing more
[Laughter]
and you get a fifty thousand dollar bed
frame what's wrong with you [ __ ]
gonna spend a million dollars [ __ ]
i don't get how his like his people's
even like let him
do all of that you know what i'm saying
because even at the at the level
i'm at when i spend like what level are
you having like
i got some money it's not crazy but like
my tax people will be like
hey what's this and this and this and
then we try to figure out okay
is this can this be business related or
is this a personal thing
like let's say i spend some money on
some like tables at a club or some [ __ ]
it's like
all right you're celebrating with your
peoples and i'm vlogging yeah we could
maybe make this expensive yeah
expensive but like on that scale how are
you
doing all that and not expecting because
he's doing this thing where
um he you know the ignite logo with the
goat horns like
he has here i i didn't get it but
oh it's this logo it's like a cult
it's like the devil so he sticks this
logo on literally
everything even though hold on is that
not ovaries
ovaries the devil women listen
so like he just like sticks his logo on
a booty and makes it a
business expense it's nexium that's what
it
is it is you could do that wait what
does ignite do it what is this company
it's
a cannabis company so like cannabis cbd
drinks water [ __ ] vape juice
bodybuilders
i always see bodybuilders at this party
you know it's funny people that are
actually in the industry like the weed
industry they were like
not once have i seen an ignite product
in the wild yeah that's what i was
wondering and supposedly
in la like they have shops that sell the
product but people are like
never seen it interesting yeah and then
um
also the the funny thing here is that
you know that super extremely lavish
bel-air home that has it's a 31 000
square foot 12 bedroom
21 bathroom home yo yes oh
dude i've seen that shit's crazy isn't
it like a hundred million dollars or
some [ __ ]
uh so he had claimed recently to have
purchased this home for 65 million
dollars
but he's renting it for
dollars a month what the [ __ ] and
recently he got kicked out
because owner of yeah he was behind
on months and in rent and then the owner
was like
oh you know i was being lenient because
you know covet times whatever but
the market's really hot right now so i
let him know he needs to get out because
i'm
going to sell this house the market's
hot for a 60 million
house well he's gonna sell it for he's
trying to get it for 75. holy [ __ ]
wait i thought he only had 50 million
dollars no
no the owner of this home is trying to
sell his home for 75 million dollars dan
bilzerian does not own this home even
though he claimed to have doesn't own
[ __ ] though 200 000 a month yeah yeah
i was supposed to go to one of his
halloween parties like some dude invited
me to this house
if that's the house he's been in yeah
then it was that house that the sky
diver flew in because that made
headlines man i don't know was this
halloween
a couple halloweens ago and me and shia
were like we just got food and we
so the way they do it is like they'll
they'll shuttle people like everyone
meets at the parking lot and then
they'll shuttle people to the
to the house and you don't have just
random people showing up yeah and like
we drove by
just like the crowd that we that we saw
that was going to the party and we were
like
maybe not let's go home it was you know
it's like a lot of like
peak right ig
um like everything for
yeah you know what i'm saying so it's
like super un like everything annoying
about hollywood
was putting in these shows everything
annoying yeah and i was just kind of
like
i was there you know like you were there
[ __ ] just poked out yeah um if i was
like singleton i would have been like
okay great vlog footage
there's ass everywhere maybe i would
have tried to get like a head behind a
bush or something yeah but then
but like going up there with wifey i was
like what's the point
it was over i was like let's go home you
know
yeah i know that definitely is something
uh to do when you're single for sure
i'm single and i don't think i'd do it i
mean single and younger
oh boy i don't think i'd do it why not
what's your reason you might have had
fun bro
if you literally gotta invite and say
well i'll go i'll go
fine i'll go you and i could have met at
this party i know that's true
yeah and following networking that's all
la's about that's you
i don't want to network with them yeah
i'll just network with sherry
right but that's the thing like you
don't know who you're making that's an
attendee
right that's a joke yeah everybody
networking at the event would have been
just people that wanted
instagram pictures for their feed also
i'm not his type
you know what i mean i'm not like the
big booty yacht type
you know i'm the small booty razor
scooter
that's my vibe oh yeah so this is like
some
like ooh stuff happening what's dan
saying
so dan is actually denying it he's just
like oh man some journalist-ass hater is
saying that i'm losing all this money
well do you
know that uber ever sent like it's a
it's worth this much
billion dollars and not one year have
they ever made a profit
okay but yeah that's like he's like just
saying like this is
this is all like uh oh he's also
tweeting out things about like
uh he tweeted a bob marley quote i
forgot what it is but pretty much saying
no woman no cry no no they hate you when
you're real
they they love you when you're fake or
something like that so he's pretty much
like
pushing it like i'm such a real person
i've not faked [ __ ] in my life i've
worked for everything i've gotten
and then everyone's like he tweets he
tweets
he tweets realize realize real life
that's a funny quote this is the home he
grew up in
god damn wait was that his dad another
picture this is his father oh
wait is he out here yeah so his dad is
actually apparently
heavily involved heavily involved in a
lot of dan's
businesses yeah which is like well
there's red flags investors
he's the criminal he's the guy that's uh
what tax evasion or whatever what
was the information do you know what do
you know how they got the money for
ignite
that's the thing that oh like the
investors i'm not like did they collect
money from investors and then dan ended
up using it all
right is that what happened okay yeah
it's the same amount yeah
we all know this is going to be like a
documentary like in a couple years he's
writing a book and i'm
super he wrote a book i don't want to
read his version
i wanna i am like okay he's actually
really [ __ ] boring during interviews
i seen him with um london reel and i
seen him with another
guy i forgot which one but i was just
like what the [ __ ] this is crazy he says
like one word answers
maybe he's trying not to tell a lie like
he's trying to like keep the answers
short
because if it's too long and people
start picking it apart he's hella mellow
too
but i think that it's interesting that
someone that seems like they have no
skills can do so much
and i think he's a good marketer that's
probably wonderful so many of those
people well apparently he's not
that good because he can't even sell his
own product
no market just getting getting into
people's eyes not like yeah
creating buzz yeah yeah yeah speaking of
ignite uh
fifty percent off right now
off the record and he got on jk news
[Music]